i Ken for other filmmakers out there who
have a foreign film that they'd like to
have remade in the States what advice
would you have for them I know Steven
Spielberg so all the film how did that
all transpire well it all we you know
after shooting this film in Quebec we
felt that this film could have an
international career and we did very
well in Canada but we also felt like a
remake could reach a broader audience so
we we start discussing with different
production companies in different
studios here in Los Angeles and finally
we got a call from dreamworks and Steven
Spielberg interested in redoing this
movie so we sat down and we really felt
that they were great great partners for
us to actually shoot a remake great
Patrick for you did you push to be in
the American version of the film what
you would not know for me brother know
whatever wouldn't have make sense no
actually makes sense at all i think i
think vince vaughn is a great choice and
the movie has to be American I mean if
you do a story about a guy who lives in
the States and you have to feel in his
DNA that he's been living there for
years otherwise it wouldn't make sense
with my accent and everything well I
think would think this with the original
we've had a very very nice career in
Canada and also internationally and now
we're coming out here in the United
States with the original where we're
very very proud of this movie here and
you know what we have accomplished with
with with this movie so that was very
exciting and we knew that there was a
potential of a remake but we made sure
that we did it in a way that this would
have its own career in them the America
version would come on right how do you
make humor universal you're so natural
in the film how do you even though if we
weren't to see the subtitles how do we
still feel that same laughs here and
there is it a wall real actually I don't
really know it's just that I come from
the stage I started as a stand-up
comedian so it's sort of a it's natural
for me to do that and and just play the
situation's the script was so well
written all of those actors were so good
all you had to do is come and walk on
stage opened and and and play with that
and I was always trying to sometimes
bring a little counterpoint when did
when it was becoming a little too
dramatic I would just do something a
little funnier and what was becoming too
just funny I was trying to bring
something human into it but otherwise
you just play those situations because
that's how life is you can we can laugh
right now and one of us in the room can
receive a phone call and we can be
crying in five minutes we don't know so
you just you just be that guy in and
play it sort of contrarian to the moment
but also I have to say something I'm a
very usually very physical actor I do a
lot I move a lot and a lot and ken was
restraining me all the time but i think
it was boiling there and you could feel
it in my eyes and in the way I was not
moving that much I was still inhabited
by all of this energy and I think that's
maybe why it goes through how is booking
work different in the States versus for
a French Canadian actor do you still
have to put in the same type of hustle
in terms of looking for your own work
not relying on an agent or manager do
you think there's a difference in the
way that actors book work in the States
versus well I don't know because I've
been
I'm doing one-man shows I'm an actor i
right I direct as well I am always
creating most of my work eh ER your own
job jobs yeah so so it's even back home
I don't I don't work I'm not waiting for
the phone to ring I'm just doing stuff
and when somebody I can call me to do
something it's just great but I don't
know how it works here and I don't even
know it works back home so obviously
it's working